a man who plotted to bomb New York City
subways could walk free from custody
within days Najibullah Zazi is being
rewarded for helping the government
identify and prosecute terrorists over
more than nine years he could have spent
the rest of his life behind bars for his
guilty plea on terrorism-related charges
but a federal judge sentence Ozzie to 10
years in prison yesterday and gave him
credit for time served
Jeff PJ's is in Washington Jeff good
morning good morning Najibullah Zazi
cooperation with US investigators earned
him his pending freedom prosecutors said
that his work as an informant has been
unprecedented and incredibly valuable
Najibullah Zazi was facing life in
prison for what authorities called one
of the most dangerous terrorist plots
since September 11 the 33 year old is a
naturalized US citizen and was
radicalized and trained by al-qaeda to
build explosives saasy and two friends
planned to detonate suicide bombs during
rush hour in New York City subways in
2009 there is no doubt that American
lives were saved then Attorney General
Eric Holder said the attack would have
been devastated after his arrest Ozzie
turned on al-qaeda he implicated his
friends and family even testifying
against one of them
Ozzie met with the government more than
100 times viewing hundreds of
photographs and providing critical
intelligence the government says Ozzy's
extraordinary assistance and insight
into al Qaeda and its members are still
helping with ongoing investigations
after Thursday's sentencing the judge
told Zazi this one unthinkable second
chance has come your way and you earned
it he's extremely appreciative and
thankful
for what happened today without question
za Z will be under supervised release or
federal probation for the rest of his
life he is expected to continue
cooperating with counterterrorism
investigations Nora
alright Jeff thank you